Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. At New Balance, we believe if you run, you're a runner. However you choose to do it. Because when you're not worried about doing things the right way, you're free to discover your way. And that's what running is all about. Run your way at newbalance.com slash running. The laws of life are always identical.
保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。在 New Balance，我们坚信只要你跑步，你就是一名跑者。无论你选择何种方式。因为当你不再担心是否以“正确”的方式做事时，你就能自由地探索属于自己的方式。而这正是跑步的真谛。在 newbalance.com/running 以你的方式奔跑。生命的法则总是相同的。
They are always the same. We do not want to rebuild our people according to abstract theories elaborated by some foreign brain, but by following the eternal laws shown to us by experience and history, and which we know. We do not live for ideas, for theories or for phantasmagorical political platforms. No, we are living and we are fighting for the German people to preserve its existence, to lead the battle it must fight for its life. So that, Tom, was Adolf Hitler on the 10th of February, 1933. It was his first big public speech as Chancellor of Germany after he was maneuvered into office by the conservative
它们总是如出一辙。我们不想根据某些外国大脑精心构思的抽象理论来重建我们的人民，而是要遵循经验和历史向我们展示的、我们所熟知的永恒法则。我们不是为了理念、理论或虚幻的政治纲领而活。不，我们活着，我们奋斗，是为了保护德意志民族的生存，去领导它为生命而必须进行的战斗。所以，汤姆，那是阿道夫·希特勒在1933年2月10日的讲话。这是他在年初被保守派民族主义者推上总理宝座后，作为德国总理发表的第一次大型公开演讲。
nationalists at the beginning of the year. It was the first campaign speech of that year's Reichstag federal elections. And that's Hitler's manifesto, isn't it? He believes, unlike Marxism, we haven't got our credo from a philosopher, from a thinker. Our ideology is grounded in concrete empirical reality. And that question of Nazi ideology is what we're going to be talking about today, isn't it? It is, because the question of why the Nazis are doing what they are doing, I think has been hanging over everything that we've done, not just in this series, but in the previous series. And we have obviously touched on it in various ways. We looked at the kind of the wellsprings of Nazism in Germany before the First World War. We've looked at how
这是当年国会大选的第一次竞选演说。那正是希特勒的宣言，不是吗？他认为，与马克思主义不同，我们不是从哲学家或思想家那里获得信条。我们的意识形态植根于具体的经验现实。而纳粹意识形态的问题正是我们今天要讨论的，对吧？确实如此，因为纳粹为什么要这样做的问题，我认为一直笼罩在我们所做的一切之上，不仅是在这个系列中，在之前的系列中也是如此。我们显然以各种方式触及过它。我们审视了第一次世界大战前德国纳粹主义的源头。我们审视了……
Nazi ideology has manifested itself at various instances while the Nazis have been in power. So Dominic, I remember in an earlier episode, you referred to Nazi idealism and then kind of immediately qualified it. You said, I mean, this will sound awful to people, but the question of were the Nazis motivated by a sense of idealism, I think has kind of been hanging over everything that we've been doing. There is no question that Hitler was a cynic. You've repeatedly talked about his genius, his malign genius for opportunism, and definitely he's a man of unspeakably violent hatreds. But is he motivated by a sense of idealism? Do the Nazis as a whole have a sense that what they're doing is for good reasons? It's a terrifying question to ask because we know where this is going. We ended the previous episode with the humiliation of Vienna's Jews. We left them scrubbing off slogans on the streets of
纳粹意识形态在纳粹掌权期间的各种表现。所以多米尼克，我记得在之前的一集里，你提到了纳粹的理想主义，然后又立即对其进行了限定。你说，我的意思是，这对人们来说听起来很可怕，但纳粹是否出于一种理想主义感而行动的问题，我认为一直笼罩在我们所做的一切之上。毫无疑问，希特勒是个愤世嫉俗者。你多次谈到他的天才，他那种邪恶的机会主义天才，而且他绝对是一个充满难以言表的暴力仇恨的人。但他是否受到理想主义感的驱使？纳粹作为一个整体，是否认为他们所做的事情是有正当理由的？这是一个令人恐惧的问题，因为我们知道事情的走向。我们在上一集结束时提到了维也纳犹太人受到的羞辱。我们看到他们被迫在维也纳街头擦洗标语，
Vienna, being beaten up by Nazi goons. we know that this is preparation for the horrors that will be unleashed during the Second World War. So, I mean, just to reiterate what that will mean, it will mean the targeted murder of six million Jews. And there will be other victims as well. So there will be maybe 250,000, some have said as many as 500,000 Roma and Sinti, gypsies as they're traditionally called. Thousands of disabled people, 10,000 to 15,000 gay men will be murdered. Meanwhile, the whole of Europe will be burning. In the East, particularly, the prosecution of the war by the Nazis will be unspeakably violent. Millions and millions of Soviet prisoners of war will die in labour camps. Almost two million Poles, for instance, will be killed. So the scale of destruction and horror, I mean, just spell it out to make it absolutely clear. Because this isn't just like another war where people die as a result of war. This is a deliberate campaign of annihilation. And that's what people have always found so shocking and what means that the Nazis have a special place, a unique place in our kind of demonology, because
被纳粹暴徒殴打。我们知道这是为第二次世界大战中将要释放的恐怖做准备。所以，我想重申一下这意味着什么，这意味着有针对性地谋杀六百万犹太人。还会有其他受害者。可能会有25万，有人说是多达50万的罗姆人和辛提人，也就是传统上所说的吉普赛人。成千上万的残疾人，1万到1.5万名男同性恋者将被谋杀。与此同时，整个欧洲都将陷入战火。特别是在东方，纳粹进行的战争将是难以言表的暴力。数以百万计的苏联战俘将死在劳改营中。例如，近两百万波兰人将被杀害。所以破坏和恐怖的规模，我的意思是，把它说清楚，让一切变得绝对清晰。因为这不仅仅是另一场战争，人们因战争而死亡。这是一场蓄意的灭绝运动。这就是人们一直感到如此震惊的原因，也意味着纳粹在我们的恶魔学中占据了一个特殊的、独特的位置，因为
the annihilation of other human beings was such a core part of their project. And that's why I guess a lot of listeners will say, how can you talk about idealism when what they represent is pure evil? But when you say the Nazis, and when we say the Nazis, I mean, who are we talking about? Are we just talking about the leadership? Are we talking about the SS? Or are we talking about a sizable number of the German population? And if the latter, then why are they doing what they're doing? Why are they committing what to us seems unspeakable crimes? Are they aware that they're the baddies? So I guess a good example to stress test that would be someone who we mentioned again in the previous episode, which is Adolf Eichmann, who is the SS guy who comes into Austria and is supervising the forced emigration of Jews to Palestine.
消灭其他人是他们计划的核心部分。这就是为什么我想很多听众会说，当他们所代表的是纯粹的邪恶时，你们怎么能谈论理想主义呢？但当你提到“纳粹”，当我们说“纳粹”时，我们指的是谁？我们是指领导层吗？我们是指党卫军吗？还是指相当一部分德国民众？如果是后者，那么他们为什么要这样做？他们为什么要犯下在我们看来难以言表的罪行？他们意识到自己是坏人吗？所以我认为一个很好的压力测试例子就是我们在上一集中提到的阿道夫·艾希曼，他是那个进入奥地利并监督将犹太人强行驱逐到巴勒斯坦的党卫军成员。
And the reason that he's a kind of interesting test case is, of course, because at the end of the war, he gets captured, then he escapes. He goes to Argentina. He is then abducted from Buenos Aires by Mossad in, what is it, 1960? Yeah. Famous trial. He is put on trial in Jerusalem and in 1962 he's convicted and he is hanged. But in that trial and in private conversations in his cell, he never shows any remorse for what he's done. And in fact, his chief regret is that the Nazis didn't go far enough. He expresses regret that the Nazis didn't end up killing 10 or 12 million Jews, because that would have then meant that Europe would have been completely Jew-free,
他之所以是一个有趣的测试案例，当然是因为在战争结束时，他被俘虏，然后逃脱了。他去了阿根廷。然后在1960年，也就是那一年，他被摩萨德从布宜诺斯艾利斯绑架。是的。著名的审判。他在耶路撒冷受审，并于1962年被定罪并绞死。但在那次审判中，以及在牢房里的私人谈话中，他从未对自己所做的事情表现出任何悔意。事实上，他最大的遗憾是纳粹做得还不够。他表示遗憾，纳粹最终没有杀掉1000万或1200万犹太人，因为那样的话，欧洲就将彻底没有犹太人了，
as he would have put it. Yeah. And just on Eichmann, I think what makes him particularly unsettling, and it's important to stress, is that before he's involved with this, he is not what we would stereotypically call a monster. He came from, I think, a reasonably successful family. His father was a bookkeeper. He came from, I think, a reasonably successful family. His father was a bookkeeper. He'd played the violin at school. He doesn't do terribly well at school, but he's a very methodical, well-organized person. He's not a serial killer.
正如他所说的那样。是的。关于艾希曼，我认为让他特别令人不安的是——强调这一点很重要——在他参与此事之前，他并不是我们刻板印象中所说的怪物。他来自一个我认为相当成功的家庭。他的父亲是一名簿记员。他来自一个我认为相当成功的家庭。他的父亲是一名簿记员。他在学校拉过小提琴。他在学校表现并不算出色，但他是一个非常有条理、组织能力很强的人。他不是连环杀手。
He's not kind of roaming the streets murdering people. He's a dutiful, conscientious, sort of high-functioning person. And what we find so shocking about the nazis is that that's true of quite a few of them you know we talked about heydrich who you know what's he do play the violin yeah or hans frank or any of these people that's what we find unsettling i think about the nazis that they're not all obvious monsters exactly because to reiterate they think they are doing the right thing and they are doing what they are doing they are doing the right thing, and they are doing what they are doing. They are presiding over genocide in response to hopes and fears that are very, very current in Germany. I think that they have an internally coherent morality. And even though by our lights, what they do has become the absolute epitome of evil. I mean, I think that they serve as for us the embodiment of evil. They do not see themselves
他不是那种在街上游荡杀人的人。他是一个尽职尽责、有良知、某种程度上高功能的人。我们觉得纳粹最令人震惊的是，他们中相当多的人都是这样。你知道，我们谈到了海德里希，他会拉小提琴，对吧？还有汉斯·弗兰克或这些人中的任何一个。我认为这就是我们觉得纳粹令人不安的地方，他们并不全是显而易见的怪物。正是因为，重申一下，他们认为自己在做正确的事，他们正在做他们正在做的事情。他们正在主持种族灭绝，以回应德国当下非常、非常普遍的希望和恐惧。我认为他们拥有一种内在连贯的道德观。即使按照我们的标准，他们的所作所为已经成为邪恶的绝对缩影。我的意思是，我认为他们对我们来说是邪恶的化身。他们并不认为自己
as evil. In fact, just the opposite. They see themselves as doing what they're doing for the good of Germany. And this is obviously really unsettling. And I mean, I don't know whether you'd agree, but I have the sense that this is a subject that historians generally have been reluctant to probe. There aren't a large number of books that kind of explore what I guess the French would call the Nazi mentality, the kind of the world vision, the understanding of the world. And I guess that there are two reasons for that. And the first is, of course, the taboo nature of Nazi beliefs, the fact that they do serve us as the embodiment of evil and i think you know i've talked about this before i think that the nazis
是邪恶的。事实上，恰恰相反。他们认为自己所做的一切是为了德国的利益。这显然非常令人不安。我的意思是，我不知道你是否同意，但我有一种感觉，这是一个历史学家通常不愿深入探讨的主题。没有多少书探讨我猜法国人所说的“纳粹心态”，那种世界观，对世界的理解。我想有两个原因。第一个当然是纳粹信仰的禁忌性质，他们确实是我们心目中邪恶的化身，我想你知道我以前谈过这个，我认为纳粹
have come to kind of replace the christian mythology with a new mythology and that just as you know in the middle ages christians wouldn't ask well why does satan why do devils do what they do they just do it because they're evil yeah i think there is a kind of sense that when we talk about what the Nazis are doing, we just think, well, they're doing it because they're Nazis and by definition, therefore they're evil. Yeah. I think there is, I think there is, we assume that there's, to use that word again, monsters. They're monsters or mad. Oh yeah, mad. So the idea that Hitler was mad or that Himmler was mad, I mean, they're pretty entrenched, aren't they? We talk about Hitler's kind of insane genius, his demented plans, all that kind of thing. But there's actually no evidence at all that Hitler was mad. I mean, Hitler wasn't mad. I mean, we may find his ideas
已经取代了基督教神话，建立了一种新的神话。就像在中世纪，基督徒不会问“为什么撒旦、为什么魔鬼要做他们所做的事”，他们只是因为邪恶而做。是的，我认为有一种感觉，当我们谈论纳粹所做的事情时，我们只是想，好吧，他们这样做是因为他们是纳粹，根据定义，他们就是邪恶的。是的。我认为存在一种假设，即他们是——再次使用那个词——怪物。他们是怪物或疯子。哦，是的，疯子。所以希特勒是疯子或者希姆莱是疯子的想法，根深蒂固，不是吗？我们谈论希特勒那种疯狂的天才，他那痴呆的计划，诸如此类。但实际上没有任何证据表明希特勒是疯子。我的意思是，希特勒并不疯狂。我的意思是，我们可能会发现他的想法
horrific, but he's not insane. He wouldn't be locked up in an asylum. So I think you're right. We tend to find that the belief system is so horrific that we don't think of it as what you described, which is an internally coherent system of morality. So it's absolutely not my period. So I'm sure there are people listening to this who will know a lot more than I do. But when I was writing Dominion about Christianity and its moral influence, I was looking for books on the idea of the kind of the Nazi morality. I couldn't actually find many.
令人毛骨悚然，但他并不疯狂。他不会被关进精神病院。所以我认为你是对的。我们倾向于认为这种信仰体系太可怕了，以至于我们不会把它看作你所描述的那样，即一个内在连贯的道德体系。所以这绝对不是我的研究领域。所以我相信听这个节目的听众中有人会比我了解得多。但当我在写关于基督教及其道德影响的《多米尼恩》（Dominion）时，我一直在寻找关于纳粹道德观的书。我实际上没找到几本。
So one is a brilliant book called The Nazi Conscience by American historian called Claudia Koontz. And the other, which I think is a really remarkable book, is by a French scholar. I think he's professor of contemporary history at the Sorbonne
其中一本是美国历史学家克劳迪娅·昆茨（Claudia Koontz）写的精彩著作《纳粹良知》（The Nazi Conscience）。另一本我认为非常了不起的书是一位法国学者写的，我想他是索邦大学的当代史教授，
called Johann Chaputet. And his book, The Law of Blood, Thinking and Acting as a Nazi. And in it, he writes, to my knowledge, no one has ever yet attempted to map out what might be called the mental universe in which Nazi crimes took place and held meaning.
名叫约翰·查普泰（Johann Chaputet）。他的书叫《血之法则：像纳粹一样思考和行动》（The Law of Blood: Thinking and Acting as a Nazi）。他在书中写道：据我所知，还没有人尝试过勾勒出纳粹罪行发生并具有意义的所谓精神宇宙。
And so that's an extraordinary book, which I commend to anyone who's kind of interested in this topic. And I think that it is true that by and large, this is an area that historians have been kind of reluctant to probe. But I think the other reason why, for instance, you compared Nazi ideology to Soviet ideology. With Soviet ideology, there is this entire framework of Marxist belief that is very amenable to academic study. You know, there are Marxists still in universities. And even if you're not a Marxist, you can study it. And, you know, there are all kinds of abstract nouns and systems that you can explore. But Hitler, of course, is rejecting that. I mean, he's explicitly displaying contempt for what, you know, to quote him, abstract theories elaborated by some foreign
所以那是一本非凡的书，我向任何对这个话题感兴趣的人推荐。我认为，总的来说，历史学家确实不愿深入探讨这个领域。但我认为另一个原因，例如，你将纳粹意识形态与苏联意识形态进行了比较。对于苏联意识形态，有一整套马克思主义信仰框架，非常适合学术研究。你知道，大学里仍然有马克思主义者。即使你不是马克思主义者，你也可以研究它。而且，你知道，有各种各样的抽象名词和系统可以探索。但希特勒当然拒绝了这一点。我的意思是，他明确表示对——引用他的话——“某些外国大脑精心构思的抽象理论”表示蔑视。
brain. I mean, he's obviously thinking of Marx there, I guess. Right. Well, that speech at the beginning of the show. Yeah. And instead he's talking about the eternal law shown to us by experience and history in which we know yeah so the we in that that is the german people and so how do they know these eternal laws by virtue of what hitler casts as their racial inheritance and the eternal laws are the laws of nature and for the Nazis, this is kind of the key division, that the laws that the German state, the Weimar state, the Wilhelmine state have had are laws that basically reflect a Jewish cast of mind, as they would describe it, kind of legalistic, dry, dead. The true laws are those that are felt like a kind of song in the blood, and only the Nordic race can properly experience that. So just to look at another talk,
我的意思是，我想他是在想马克思。没错。好吧，节目开头的那段演讲。是的。相反，他谈论的是“经验和历史向我们展示的永恒法则，我们所熟知的”。是的，所以其中的“我们”是指德国人民。那么他们是如何通过希特勒所说的种族传承来了解这些永恒法则的呢？永恒法则是自然法则。对于纳粹来说，这是一个关键的分歧，即魏玛国家、威廉时代国家所拥有的法律，基本上反映了他们所描述的犹太人的思维方式，即法律主义的、枯燥的、死板的。真正的法律是那些像血液中的歌声一样被感受到的法律，只有北欧种族才能真正体验到这一点。所以，让我们看看另一场演讲，
and this was given by Heinrich Himmler, head of the SS in 1936, and he tackles headlong the idea that the Nazi state is a lawless state. And he recognizes that this is how it's seen abroad in other countries. So he's addressing the German Academy of Law. And he says that he knows that the Nazi state is seen as a lawless police state, that there's talk of lawlessness because what we were doing did not correspond to what they, i.e. people in the democracies and so on, understood by the word law. But in truth, with our work, we are laying the foundations of a new law, the German people's right to life. And Himmler explains that this law is the most ancient law of our people, and that it is a law that back in the happy early primordial days of the German people,
这是党卫军首领海因里希·希姆莱在1936年发表的，他正面回应了纳粹国家是一个无法律国家的观点。他认识到这在国外其他国家是被这样看待的。所以他在向德国法律学院发表讲话。他说他知道纳粹国家被视为一个无法律的警察国家，有人谈论无法律，因为我们所做的事情与他们（即民主国家的人民等）对“法律”一词的理解不符。但事实上，通过我们的工作，我们正在奠定新法律的基础，即德国人民的生存权。希姆莱解释说，这条法律是我们民族最古老的法律，这是一条在德国人民快乐的早期原始时代，
they instinctively understood this. So this is when they are kind of lurking in forests, pre-Roman Empire or during the Roman Empire, in clans or whatever. They're very hirsute. This is Himmler's kind of vision. This is certainly what Himmler thinks, yes. Whether Hitler does will come to that in a few minutes. But yes, that they live in harmony with this sense of law, and that is what enables them to thrive. This sense of law is basically survival of the fittest. The fact that life is tough, that you have to strain hard to do down your enemies and to prevail for the good of your people. The tragedy of the Germans is that they have forgotten this, but there is hope. The
他们本能地理解的法律。所以这是当他们潜伏在森林里，罗马帝国之前或期间，在氏族中或无论什么地方。他们毛发浓密。这是希姆莱的愿景。这当然是希姆莱的想法，是的。希特勒是否也这样认为，我们几分钟后再谈。但是的，他们与这种法律感和谐相处，这使他们能够茁壮成长。这种法律感基本上就是适者生存。生活是艰难的，你必须努力奋斗去打倒你的敌人，为了你人民的利益而获胜。德国人的悲剧在于他们忘记了这一点，但还有希望。
situation is not completely lost. The German people remain the German people still because the Nazis have a completely essentialist idea of race. If you're a German back in the shaggy forests or a German now, you're still a German. Your racial makeup is unchanging. And the Nazi mission is to reclaim that racial inheritance. And so Himmler sums it up, the basic concepts of our law must's ideas about struggle and about competition and about the survival of the fittest have kind of percolated into society. And so, I mean, we've mentioned a few times, Hitler's ideology is basically stuff that he's picked up by reading in journals that were published in the 1890s, 1900s, that are full of all this stuff about your racial
情况并没有完全绝望。德国人民仍然是德国人民，因为纳粹对种族有一种完全本质主义的观念。无论你是多毛森林里的德国人，还是现在的德国人，你仍然是德国人。你的种族构成是不变的。纳粹的使命是收回那种种族传承。所以希姆莱总结道，我们法律的基本概念必须……关于斗争和竞争以及适者生存的想法已经渗透到社会中。所以，我的意思是，我们提到了几次，希特勒的意识形态基本上是他通过阅读1890年代、1900年代出版的期刊所学到的东西，这些期刊里充满了关于你的种族
inheritance and this kind of racial essentialism, which is such a key part of the nationalism that thrives at the turn of the 20th century. Completely. Hitler and the Nazis generally think they are following the science. I mean, it's a phrase we've used throughout this series. They see themselves as scientific. Their racism is scientific and it is founded in the idea of struggle. So, Chapiteau, in his book, he describes a documentary that was put out in 1937 by the Office of Racial Purity. And you can see it online. It's on YouTube. It's called Alice Leben ist Kampf. All life is struggle. So there's that, you know, that echo of Mein Kampf. It's all the struggle. And it's basically encouraging the Germans to recognise that the only way that they as a race can survive is to kind of purge themselves of effete compassion and to commit themselves wholeheartedly to struggle. charging each other and monkeys ripping arms off each other and birds attacking one another. And then you have trees competing for light in forests. And you have this phrase, the weak and the non-viable must submit to the strong. Nature allows only the best vital force
传承和这种种族本质主义的内容，这是20世纪之交盛行的民族主义的关键部分。完全正确。希特勒和纳粹通常认为他们是在遵循科学。我的意思是，这是我们在整个系列中一直使用的短语。他们认为自己是科学的。他们的种族主义是科学的，它建立在斗争的观念之上。所以，查普泰在他的书中描述了一部1937年由种族纯洁办公室制作的纪录片。你可以在网上看到它。它在YouTube上。它叫《Alles Leben ist Kampf》。一切生命皆是斗争。所以，你知道，那是《我的奋斗》的回声。一切皆是斗争。它基本上是在鼓励德国人认识到，他们作为一个种族能够生存的唯一途径，就是净化自己，摆脱软弱的同情心，全心全意地投入到斗争中。互相冲撞，猴子撕扯对方的手臂，鸟儿互相攻击。然后你有森林里争夺阳光的树木。你有这样一句话：弱者和不可行的必须服从强者。自然只允许最好的生命力
to survive. And this may seem a harsh message, but this propaganda film frames it actually as being something to celebrate because it is what makes possible, the film says, the perfection of all living things. And that message having been delivered, you then get lots of kind of stirring footage of elephants and tigers and so on. And the Nazis are obviously casting themselves and the German people as the equivalent of kind of megfauna, apex mammals. But this is a perspective that in the 1930s is being offered in a spirit of self-pity as well as of triumphalism, because the Nazis have come to power haunted by a sense that the German race is under threat, that Germany is besieged, that it's weak, that it's menaced with the risk of complete oblivion. And this is what explains the urgency of the Nazi mission and why it is consistently being framed in biological terms. Because they believe that the moment of crisis is at hand, right? That this is, as it were, the end times, that the biological struggle is reaching its
生存。这可能看起来是一个严酷的信息，但这部宣传片实际上将其描述为值得庆祝的事情，因为它使一切生物的完美成为可能。在传达了这一信息后，你会看到许多令人振奋的关于大象、老虎等的镜头。纳粹显然将他们自己和德国人民塑造成了某种巨型动物、顶级哺乳动物的等价物。但这是一种在1930年代以自怜和胜利主义精神提出的观点，因为纳粹掌权时，一直被一种德国种族受到威胁、德国被围困、虚弱、面临彻底毁灭风险的感觉所困扰。这就是为什么纳粹使命具有紧迫性，以及为什么它始终以生物学术语来表述的原因。因为他们相信危机时刻已经到来，对吧？这就是所谓的末日，生物斗争正在达到其
climax. Yes. And so, of course, Hitler's been raised a Catholic. He is aware of, say, Christian teachings for the weak and the disadvantaged and the poor. So he knows that what he's saying is liable to be shocking to many people in Germany. But he's absolutely upfront about the fact that basically the German people need to man up, as Hitler might have put it. To quote him, certainly one might find it horrifying to observe that in nature one animal devours another. But one thing is certain, nothing can be done to change it. One cannot rise up against the firmament. If one must believe at all costs in a divine commandment, then it should be this one, to preserve the race.
高潮。是的。当然，希特勒是作为天主教徒长大的。他了解，比如说，基督教对弱者、弱势群体和穷人的教导。所以他知道他所说的话可能会让德国的许多人感到震惊。但他非常坦率地承认，基本上德国人民需要“硬起来”，正如希特勒可能说的那样。引用他的话：当然，观察到自然界中一种动物吞噬另一种动物可能会让人感到恐惧。但有一点是肯定的，没有任何办法可以改变它。一个人不能反抗苍穹。如果一个人必须不惜一切代价相信神圣的诫命，那么它应该是这一条：保护种族。
So that obsession with race is rooted in the Nazi understanding of biology, but it is also rooted in the Nazi understanding of history. Because obviously, if you were making the argument that the German people in, say, 1935 are the same as the German people back in the primordial mists of time, then you need to demonstrate that by constructing an account of history that makes sense of that argument. As it happens, and not coincidentally, history was actually Hitler's favourite subject at school. It was the one subject at which he excelled. His history teacher was the one teacher he really admired and respected. And by the time he comes to write Mein Kampf, he has come to a quite coherent understanding of history as a kind of record of perpetual racial struggle. And the reason that he's interested in history, that he's an incredible autodidact, he reads a lot about it. It's not that
所以对种族的痴迷植根于纳粹对生物学的理解，但也植根于纳粹对历史的理解。因为显然，如果你提出这样的论点，即1935年的德国人民与原始时间迷雾中的德国人民是同一个人，那么你需要通过构建一种能够解释该论点的历史叙述来证明这一点。巧合的是，历史实际上是希特勒在学校最喜欢的科目。这是他表现最出色的科目。他的历史老师是他真正钦佩和尊敬的老师。到他写《我的奋斗》时，他已经对历史有了一种相当连贯的理解，将其视为一种永恒种族斗争的记录。他之所以对历史感兴趣，是因为他是一个不可思议的自学者，他读了很多关于历史的书。并不是
he's interested in history for its own sake, but that it teaches lessons. So he's overt about this in Mein Kampf. He says, we do not study history simply to know the past. We study history so as to find an instructor for the future and for the continued existence of our own race. So it's purely didactic. It's something that everyone should look at to learn their racial destiny. But of course, there is a problem for the Nazis that you touched on earlier, where you talked about the Germans living in their dripping forests and so on, and they're all very hairy and shaggy. And this is kind of a bit embarrassing because they're a bit rubbish. They're not the Romans, are they? I mean, they're not the ancient Greeks or something. Right. So if the ancient Germans are so fitted for rule and for great cultural achievement, then where's the evidence? And Himmler, of course, famously looks for it within Germany himself. So he is commissioning teams of SS archaeologists across Germany and look for evidence of the great cultural achievements of
因为他为了历史本身而对历史感兴趣，而是因为它能传授教训。所以他在《我的奋斗》中对此直言不讳。他说，我们研究历史不仅仅是为了了解过去。我们研究历史是为了为未来和我们自己种族的持续生存寻找导师。所以它是纯粹的说教。这是每个人都应该审视以了解其种族命运的东西。但当然，纳粹存在一个你之前提到的问题，当你谈到德国人生活在滴水的森林里等等，他们都非常多毛和蓬乱。这有点尴尬，因为他们有点垃圾。他们不是罗马人，对吧？我的意思是，他们不是古希腊人什么的。没错。所以如果古代德国人如此适合统治和取得伟大的文化成就，那么证据在哪里？希特勒当然，希特勒……希姆莱当然，他自己就在德国寻找证据。所以他委托党卫军考古学家团队在德国各地寻找古代德国人伟大文化成就的证据。
the ancient Germans. Occult artefacts and stuff, you know, the Holy Grail or whatever. You know, he's all into that, isn't he? But not even that. I mean, basically, they're digging up Bronze Age or Iron Age pots and displaying them with great pride and everything. But they're a bit rubbish. And Hitler knows that they're rubbish, and he finds it embarrassing. And he says, look, the stuff that the Germans are producing in prehistory,
神秘的文物之类的，你知道，圣杯什么的。你知道，他沉迷于此，不是吗？但甚至不是那样。我的意思是，基本上，他们挖出青铜时代或铁器时代的陶罐，并非常自豪地展示它们等等。但它们有点垃圾。希特勒知道它们是垃圾，他觉得很尴尬。他说，看，德国人在史前时期生产的东西，
he compares it specifically to the Maori in New Zealand. He says, this is the level that they're on. And this really isn't good enough for Hitler. If the Germans are the master race, then it's not enough for them just to be producing kind of a few rubbish bits of pottery. They need to be producing palpable evidence of their cultural greatness. This is very harsh on the Maoris, by the way, Tom. I am quoting Hitler. I'm making no comments myself. So he looks elsewhere for the ancient vitality of the Nordic race. And specifically, he looks southwards and he looks to the great radiant centres of ancient civilisation in Europe, which are, of course, Greece and Rome. And Hitler says, again, to quote him, I cannot help remembering that while our ancestors were making these vessels of stone and clay over which our archaeologists rave, the Greeks had already built an Acropolis.
他特别将其与新西兰的毛利人进行了比较。他说，这就是他们所处的水平。这对希特勒来说真的不够好。如果德国人是优等种族，那么仅仅生产一些垃圾陶器是不够的。他们需要生产出他们文化伟大的明显证据。顺便说一句，汤姆，这对毛利人来说太苛刻了。我是在引用希特勒。我自己没有发表任何评论。所以他在别处寻找北欧种族古代的活力。具体来说，他向南看，看向欧洲古代文明伟大的辐射中心，当然就是希腊和罗马。希特勒再次引用他的话说：我忍不住想起，当我们的祖先正在制作那些让我们的考古学家赞叹不已的石制和粘土容器时，希腊人已经建造了卫城。
To be fair, he's not entirely wrong, Tom. Well, he's not. And the reason that he can say this and feel that he's not in any way dissing the racial heritage of the Germans is that he's basically saying that the Greeks and the Romans are the racial kin of the Germans. Crikey, that's an unexpected move. But again, as so often with Nazi ideas, it's not one that Hitler has made up. It's one that he has picked up from very, very reputable strands of intellectual opinion in
公平地说，他并不完全错误，汤姆。嗯，他没有。他之所以能这样说，并觉得他没有以任何方式贬低德国人的种族遗产，是因为他基本上是在说希腊人和罗马人是德国人的种族亲属。天哪，这是一个意想不到的举动。但同样，正如纳粹思想中经常出现的那样，这不是希特勒编造的。这是他从19世纪德国非常、非常受人尊敬的知识观点中汲取的。
19th century Germany. Basically, all German historians and classicists are massively invested in this idea that the Germans are part of a Nordic race as the Greeks and the Romans are, that the North is the womb of Aryans. They famously come to be called the Aryans. So it's not just Greece and Rome, it's India, it's Persia. Some even go so far as to say the great pharaohs in Egypt and even the ruling dynasties in China. They're Aryan too. Wow. They're all Aryan. And that wherever there is a kind of great ancient civilization, it's the Nordic race that is responsible for it. And this is why the swastika has such a kind of key role for the Nazis, because you find the swastika in Northern India and across supposedly
基本上，所有德国历史学家和古典学者都大规模地投入到这个想法中，即德国人是北欧种族的一部分，希腊人和罗马人也是，北方是雅利安人的子宫。他们后来被称为雅利安人。所以不仅仅是希腊和罗马，还有印度、波斯。有些人甚至走得更远，说埃及的伟大法老，甚至中国的统治王朝。他们也是雅利安人。哇。他们都是雅利安人。无论哪里有某种伟大的古代文明，都是北欧种族负责的。这就是为什么万字旗对纳粹有如此关键的作用，因为你在北印度和整个所谓的
this kind of Aryan world. And so the Nazis adopt it as a symbol of their identity with this ancient culture. And Tom, I suppose what you could say is that this is merely a very, very outlandish version of what almost all nationalist movements are doing in the late 19th and early 20th century, which is inventing these glorious paths for themselves, finding spurious links with ancient civilizations. I mean, Balkan nationalists are doing it. You could argue that the British are doing it with their talk of Anglo-Saxon liberty, that the Irish are doing it. You could argue that the British are doing it with their talk of Anglo-Saxon liberty, that the Irish are doing it. Wherever you find historians and folklorists, and indeed politicians, at the late 19th, early 20th century, you find people
这种雅利安世界中都能找到万字旗。所以纳粹将其作为他们与这种古代文化认同的象征。汤姆，我想你可以说，这仅仅是19世纪末和20世纪初几乎所有民族主义运动都在做的事情的一个非常、非常古怪的版本，那就是为自己发明这些光荣的道路，寻找与古代文明的虚假联系。我的意思是，巴尔干民族主义者在这样做。你可以争辩说英国人在用他们关于盎格鲁-撒克逊自由的言论这样做，爱尔兰人在这样做。无论你在19世纪末、20世纪初找到历史学家和民俗学家，甚至是政治家，你都会发现人们
inventing these links to this sort of, as you described it, a radiant ancient history. Absolutely. But no one weaponizes it, and I use the word advisedly, quite like Hitler does. And because Hitler is the Fuhrer and therefore the embodiment of the German state, it's his perspective that basically wins out. So Himmler continues to send his SS men to grub around for pots. But it's Hitler's vision of the Greeks and the Romans being part of this Nordic race that essentially is a key driver of Nazi ideology and the way that the Nazis understand themselves and what they're doing. So essentially what Hitler is arguing, and this of course then percolates down through all the various levels of Nazi society,
发明了这些与你所描述的那种光辉古代历史的联系。绝对是这样。但没有人像希特勒那样将其武器化——我慎重地使用了这个词。因为希特勒是元首，因此是德国国家的化身，所以基本上是他的观点胜出了。所以希姆莱继续派他的党卫军去挖掘陶罐。但希特勒关于希腊人和罗马人是这个北欧种族一部分的愿景，本质上是纳粹意识形态的一个关键驱动力，也是纳粹理解自己和他们所作所为的方式。所以基本上希特勒所争论的，当然这随后渗透到纳粹社会的各个层面，
is that the Greeks and the Romans come from the North as conquerors. They are blonde, so you start getting all kinds of scholars. I mean, so there's one scholar who writes a book called The Blonde Hair of the Indo-Germanic Peoples of Antiquity. And he's gone through every classical reference to blonde hair, kind of compiling exhaustive lists. And this means, of course, that the Athenians, the Spartans, the Romans can provide the Nazis with role models. So Athens in its golden age is presided over by Pericles, of course, the great hero of Boris Johnson, but he's also a particular hero of Hitler. And Pericles is cast as a Fuhrer, as a leader, who is also an artist.
是希腊人和罗马人作为征服者来自北方。他们是金发的，所以你开始得到各种各样的学者。我的意思是，有一位学者写了一本书，叫《古代印欧民族的金发》。他翻遍了每一条关于金发的古典参考资料，整理出详尽的清单。这意味着，当然，雅典人、斯巴达人、罗马人可以为纳粹提供榜样。所以雅典在黄金时代由伯里克利主持，当然，他是鲍里斯·约翰逊的伟大英雄，但他也是希特勒特别的英雄。伯里克利被塑造成一个元首，一个也是艺术家的领导者。
But he didn't have blonde hair, did he? Pericles? Surely not. He has a kind of long skull, which is identified by Nazi racial theorists as a marker of the Aryans. So this is kind of seen as evidence. Like Virginia Woolf, she had a very long face. Anyway, that's by the by. Well, there you go. Sparta is defined by Hitler as the first racial estate, you know, enormous inspiration to him. And Rome above all is what provides Hitler with both a kind of a model and a challenge.
但他没有金发，对吧？伯里克利？肯定没有。他有一种长头骨，被纳粹种族理论家认定为雅利安人的标志。所以这被视为证据。就像弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，她有一张非常长的脸。总之，那是题外话。好吧，给你。斯巴达被希特勒定义为第一个种族国家，你知道，对他有巨大的启发。而罗马最重要的是为希特勒提供了一个模型和一个挑战。
And so Hitler describes Roman history as being the best teacher. And he admires pretty much everything, not about the mass of the Roman people, but about the Roman elites, the Romans who are guiding Rome to Mediterranean supremacy. He admires everything about them, their customs, their mores, even their teeth. He's very into the idea that they had excellent teeth, and this is proof of their kind of Germanic heritage. Wow, who knew? And, you know, the evidence for this is evident when you look at the iconography of Nazism.
所以希特勒将罗马历史描述为最好的老师。他几乎钦佩所有东西，不是关于罗马大众，而是关于罗马精英，那些引导罗马走向地中海霸权的罗马人。他钦佩关于他们的一切，他们的习俗、他们的风俗，甚至他们的牙齿。他非常沉迷于他们有极好的牙齿的想法，这是他们某种日耳曼遗产的证明。哇，谁知道呢？而且，你知道，当你观察纳粹主义的肖像时，证据是显而易见的。
The eagles. Standards, yeah. The standards, the eagles, the style of architecture, you know, like Pericles and Phidias, who designed the Parthenon, Hitler and Speer. It's seen as the same relationship. And Hitler's model for Berlin, this great city that he's going to call Germania, which is the Latin word for Germany, it's all kind of modelled very, very consciously on Roman architecture. But I think the thing that Rome particularly provides Hitler is an example in history of a great power conquering the world, basically. The Romans conquered the known world, and this provides Hitler with the model. A thousand-year Reich,
鹰。旗帜，是的。旗帜、鹰、建筑风格，你知道，就像设计帕台农神庙的伯里克利和菲迪亚斯，希特勒和施佩尔。这被视为同样的关系。希特勒为柏林设计的模型，这个他打算称之为“日耳曼尼亚”（Germania，这是德国的拉丁语名称）的伟大城市，都是非常有意识地以罗马建筑为蓝本的。但我认为罗马特别为希特勒提供的是一个历史上大国征服世界的例子，基本上。罗马人征服了已知世界，这为希特勒提供了模型。千年帝国，
right? All that kind of thing, yes. So the ancient Greeks, the ancient Romans, these are basically Nordic people. They provide evidence that the Nordic races are superior, that they are racially attuned to conquest and cultural supremacy. So what goes wrong? And this is where Hitler's understanding of history darkens, because it's obvious that things do go wrong. Athenian civilization collapses, Sparta collapses, the Roman Empire collapses. And Hitler's explanation for this is twofold. Firstly, miscegenation, that both in Athens and in Rome, the Germanic elites start to breed with inferior races, and therefore the purity of the racial stock is corrupted. But also, they are targeted by the supreme, the eternal, the utterly malignant opponents of the Nordic race,
对吧？所有这些东西，是的。所以古希腊人、古罗马人，这些基本上是北欧人。他们提供了证据，证明北欧种族是优越的，他们从种族上适应了征服和文化霸权。那么出了什么问题？这就是希特勒对历史的理解变得黑暗的地方，因为很明显事情确实出了问题。雅典文明崩溃了，斯巴达崩溃了，罗马帝国崩溃了。希特勒对此的解释是双重的。首先是混血，在雅典和罗马，日耳曼精英开始与劣等种族繁衍，因此种族血统的纯洁性被腐蚀了。但同时，他们也成为了北欧种族至高无上、永恒、完全恶毒的对手的目标，
which is the Jews. And the reason, the biological, I use inverted commas, the biological reason why the Jews hate the Nordic race is because the Jews themselves are a kind of anti-race. They are a racial melting pot in which, so this is an official account by the SS Department of Racial Expertise, the Jew is a bastard, an aggregate of the oriental, the Asian, of Asia Minor, the hermetic, the negro. So it's the fact that the Jew is a figure in which all these various racial elements have met and been degraded that primes the Jews to hate the racial purity of the Aryans and to target them. Right. Because it's not just that they regard the Jews as, as it were, satanic. That point
那就是犹太人。犹太人憎恨北欧种族的原因——生物学上的，我用引号，生物学上的原因——是因为犹太人本身就是一种“反种族”。他们是一个种族大熔炉，所以这是党卫军种族专业部门的官方说法，犹太人是一个杂种，是东方人、亚洲人、小亚细亚人、闪米特人、黑人的集合体。所以正是犹太人是一个所有这些不同种族元素相遇并退化的形象，这使得犹太人憎恨雅利安人的种族纯洁性并以他们为目标。没错。因为不仅仅是他们认为犹太人是——姑且称之为——撒旦。那一点
about them being degenerate is really important, isn't it? They are kind of biologically the opposite. They are unhealthy. They are a debased version of what humanity should be, all of that kind of thing. There's almost a kind of weird squeamishness to the way that the Nazis talk about the Jews when they talk about them as a virus, as a bacilli, all of those kinds of things. It's not just that they're wicked, which the Nazis believe they are, or that they're corrupt or any of those things. It's that they are somehow inhuman. I mean, I think the Nazis do, of course, in their guts, think that the Jews are wicked or satanic. But publicly, they often deny this. They say, you know, we feel no animus against the Jews. We don't see them as evil. Basile, you wouldn't complain about Basile. And they just do what they
关于他们是退化的，真的很重要，不是吗？他们在生物学上是相反的。他们是不健康的。他们是人类应该成为的样子的一种堕落版本，所有这些东西。纳粹谈论犹太人时，当他们谈论他们是病毒、是杆菌、所有这些东西时，几乎有一种奇怪的厌恶感。不仅仅是他们是邪恶的，纳粹相信他们是，或者他们是腐败的或任何这些东西。而是他们以某种方式是不人道的。我的意思是，我认为纳粹当然在内心深处认为犹太人是邪恶的或撒旦的。但公开地，他们经常否认这一点。他们说，你知道，我们对犹太人没有敌意。我们不认为他们是邪恶的。杆菌，你不会抱怨杆菌。他们只是做他们
do. They try and frame it in scientific terms yeah but of course i mean they're using this scientific language to justify deep hideous prejudice but i think they would say that it's a kind of scientific understanding both of biology and of history because what hitler is doing when he looks at the past and what happens say to the roman empire he's's saying, look how you can see the evidence of Jewish malignity. And the evidence for this is the rise of Christianity. So he sees St. Paul, who of course is a Jew, as the embodiment of Jewish hatred for everything that makes the Nordic race supreme. So Paul preaches a doctrine of compassion for the
做的事。他们试图用科学术语来表达它，是的。但当然，我的意思是，他们正在使用这种科学语言来为深刻、丑陋的偏见辩护。但我认为他们会说，这是一种对生物学和历史的科学理解。因为希特勒在审视过去以及发生在罗马帝国身上的事情时，他是在说，看，你如何能看到犹太人恶毒的证据。而这方面的证据就是基督教的兴起。所以他认为圣保罗，当然他是一个犹太人，是犹太人憎恨一切使北欧种族至高无上的东西的化身。所以保罗宣扬了一种对……的同情学说。
poor, universalism, all these things that the Nazis detest. Himmler condemns the early Christians very, very explicitly as the most repugnant Jewish element, the most disgusting bunch of reds. This seems to me, actually, the most grotesque paradox of the whole horror of the Nazi persecution of the Jews is that basically they're persecuting the Jews and blaming them for Christianity. And it's Christianity, of course, that historically has provided the sanction for persecution of the Jews. So it's a hideous, hideous paradox. Because one of the things that's interesting about Nazi antisemitism, obviously Nazi antisemitism comes out of the climate again of the late 19th century. There's always been antisemitism, but antisemitism had changed, hadn't it, in the 19th century from a largely religious prejudice to a very overtly racial one. So sometimes people argue about this, don't they? I mean, there's arguments at the moment. Is antisemitism a form of racism? And clearly Nazi antisemitism absolutely is, because it's based not on a prejudice of a Christian against a Jew. It's a racial prejudice. This idea of biology is absolutely central to it. and that it exists to corrupt and corrode the traditional Nordic sense of the laws of nature
贫穷、普世主义，所有这些纳粹所厌恶的东西。希姆莱非常明确地谴责早期基督徒是“最令人反感的犹太分子”，是“最令人作呕的红党分子”。在我看来，这实际上是纳粹迫害犹太人这一恐怖行径中最荒诞的悖论：他们迫害犹太人，却又因为基督教而指责他们。而众所周知，历史上正是基督教为迫害犹太人提供了制裁依据。所以这是一个极其丑陋的悖论。因为纳粹反犹主义有趣的一点在于，它显然源于19世纪末的社会氛围。反犹主义一直存在，但在19世纪，它从一种主要的宗教偏见转变为一种极其公开的种族偏见。有时人们会争论这一点，对吧？目前确实存在争议：反犹主义是一种种族主义吗？显然纳粹反犹主义绝对是，因为它不是基于基督徒对犹太人的偏见，而是一种种族偏见。这种生物学观念是其核心，它认为这种偏见的存在是为了腐蚀和破坏传统的北欧自然法则。
by kind of introducing compassion for the weak and the poor and all this kind of thing. And that the whole of Western history from the collapse of the Roman Empire is a demonstration of how this meme is percolating and corrupting and destroying the Nordic race. So it's this meme, if you want to put it that way, that generates the Catholic body of law in the Middle Ages that occludes and destroys the traditional German understanding of the laws of nature. You have the Germanic elites of Christian Europe engaged in war with the popes and the Catholic lawyers. This reaches right the way up to the French Revolution, which again is cast in overtly racial terms. So the elites that get destroyed in the French
通过引入对弱者和穷人的同情心等等。从罗马帝国崩溃以来的整个西方历史，都是这种“模因”如何渗透、腐蚀和摧毁北欧种族的证明。所以，如果可以这样说的话，正是这种“模因”催生了中世纪的天主教法典，它遮蔽并摧毁了德国人对自然法则的传统理解。基督教欧洲的日耳曼精英们与教皇和天主教律师们陷入了战争。这种情况一直持续到法国大革命，而法国大革命同样被赋予了明显的种族色彩。所以，在法国大革命中被摧毁的精英们
Revolution are cast as Aryan, kind of blondes. And the plebs, the masses, the people are cast as in some way the embodiment of this kind of this Jewish resentment of a degenerate mass. And the ideals of the French revolution. So what Alfred Rosenberg describes as the infamous slogan of liberty, equality, fraternity, you know, it gets carried into Germany by Napoleon and infects Germany. And in the long run will give rise to Bolshevism, which is the ultimate expression of this to the Nazi way of thinking, eternal and inveterate Jewish hatred for everything that the German people represent. So in other words, it's the Germans who are the real victims in this story.
被描绘成雅利安人，即金发碧眼的人。而平民、大众、人民则被描绘成某种程度上是这种犹太人对堕落大众的怨恨的化身。还有法国大革命的理想。阿尔弗雷德·罗森堡所描述的那个臭名昭著的口号——自由、平等、博爱，你知道，它被拿破仑带入德国并感染了德国。从长远来看，它将导致布尔什维克主义，在纳粹看来，这是犹太人对德国人民所代表的一切永恒且根深蒂固的仇恨的终极表现。换句话说，在这个故事中，德国人才是真正的受害者。
Right. Because they've been cheated of their rightful place at the top of the evolutionary ladder, if that's a viable metaphor. Exactly. Yes. And it's been a continuous and ongoing war launched against them by the Jews. So their ability to identify with their primal law has been corrupted by this kind of Jewish style of legalism. Their will to power has been softened by Christian compassion and by the egalitarianism that's been preached by the French Revolution. They are hemmed in all around by Slavs and other racial inferiors who are outbreeding them. And they've been bled of their manpower by the bloodletting in the Great War.
没错。因为他们被剥夺了在进化阶梯顶端应有的位置，如果这是一个可行的比喻的话。正是如此。是的。这是一场由犹太人对他们发动的持续不断的战争。他们认同自身原始法则的能力被这种犹太式的法律主义所腐蚀。他们的权力意志被基督教的同情心和法国大革命所宣扬的平等主义所软化。他们被斯拉夫人和其他种族劣等者包围，这些人正在通过繁衍超过他们。而且，他们在“大战”中的流血牺牲也耗尽了他们的人力。
And these are the perils that haunt Hitler and which he is determined to see off. And this is what has always inspired him. So in 1922, he'd said that long ago when Rome was collapsing, an endless flow of Germanic hordes came from the north to save it. So that's casting the barbarian invasions as basically replenishing the depleted Nordic blood of the Roman state. Oh, right. Yeah. But if Germany disappears, who will come after? Little by little, Germanic blood is being drained from this earth unless we pick ourselves up again and set ourselves free. And in 1922, that might seem a pipe dream, but in the 1930s, Hitler is in power and he is in a position to act
这些就是困扰希特勒并让他决心消除的危险。这正是他一直以来的灵感来源。所以，在1922年，他说过，很久以前当罗马崩溃时，无尽的日耳曼部落从北方涌来拯救它。这实际上是将蛮族入侵视为补充罗马帝国枯竭的北欧血液。哦，对。是的。但如果德国消失了，谁会接替呢？除非我们重新振作起来并获得自由，否则日耳曼人的血液正一点一点地从这个地球上流失。在1922年，这可能看起来是个白日梦，但在20世纪30年代，希特勒掌权了，他有能力采取行动
on that understanding of history and of biology. All right. Well, we'll take a break right now, and we will return to discuss exactly how Hitler goes about trying to put that into operation. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
基于那种对历史和生物学的理解。好了，我们现在休息一下，回来后我们将讨论希特勒究竟是如何试图将其付诸实施的。休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. We do not start from the individual. We do not believe that the starving should be fed, that the thirsty should be given to drink, that the naked should be clothed. These are not valuable motives in our eyes. Our motives are of an entirely different nature. They may thus be summed up in a lapidary manner. We must have a healthy people to dominate in the world. That was Joseph Goebbels, Tom, in 1938, talking about Nazi morality. Now, Theo, our producer, has asked me to stress, Theo obviously holds the listeners in low regard
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。我们不从个人出发。我们不相信饥饿者应被喂饱，口渴者应被给予饮水，赤身者应被给予衣物。在我们眼中，这些不是有价值的动机。我们的动机性质完全不同。它们可以用一种简练的方式总结：我们必须拥有一个健康的民族来统治世界。那是约瑟夫·戈培尔，汤姆，在1938年谈论纳粹道德。现在，我们的制片人西奥要求我强调一下，西奥显然对听众评价不高
because he's worried that listeners will think that we ourselves are Nazis. Tom, are you a Nazi? I'm happy to put on record I'm not a Nazi. So we don't actually agree with these quotations, do we, Tom? It's very important. Let's just emphasize that. Now, so Goebbels' idea of morality is basically that everything is about health. I mean, the Nazis are obsessed with hygiene, aren't they? Racial health. Racial hygiene, yeah. So what is moral is what benefits the German people, and anything that doesn't benefit them- Is immoral.
因为他担心听众会认为我们自己也是纳粹。汤姆，你是纳粹吗？我很乐意记录在案，我不是纳粹。所以我们实际上并不认同这些引言，对吧，汤姆？这一点非常重要。让我们强调一下。那么，戈培尔的道德观基本上就是一切都与健康有关。我的意思是，纳粹对卫生非常痴迷，不是吗？种族健康。种族卫生，是的。所以，什么是道德的，就是对德国人民有益的，而任何对他们无益的——就是不道德的。
Is either amoral or immoral. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And so this is a message that is over the course of the thirties being endlessly pumped out by the Nazi leadership, by the SS, by propagandists, by academics, by public officials, by teachers. I mean, it is relentless. So if you're a child, you get this in school, you get this in the Hitler Youth, you get this on the radio, you see it in posters. Now, here's my question. Everything that we've talked about so far, the ideas about ancient Greece and Rome
要么是无道德的，要么是不道德的。是的，完全正确。是的。所以，这是一个在整个三十年代被纳粹领导层、党卫军、宣传家、学者、公职人员、教师不断灌输的信息。我的意思是，这是无情的。所以如果你是个孩子，你在学校里会听到这些，在希特勒青年团里会听到这些，在广播里会听到这些，你在海报上也会看到这些。现在，我的问题是。到目前为止我们谈论的一切，关于古希腊和罗马的想法
and all that sort of stuff, obviously most ordinary people, if you're a kind of lathe operator in Hamburg, you're probably not thinking about the Romans very much or indeed the sort of origins of the Germanic race or any of this stuff. So how much do you think these ideas, some of which are pretty fringe ideas, how much have they seeped into the German population as a whole during the course of the 1930s? Well, that's hugely debated, isn't it? And I certainly don't feel qualified to rule on that. But my sense would be that the war would not have been fought in the way it was, had large numbers of people not kind of accepted, maybe even in just a gut way, the essential validity of what was being propagated.
以及所有这些东西，显然大多数普通人，如果你是汉堡的一个车床操作工，你可能不会太考虑罗马人，或者说日耳曼种族的起源之类的东西。那么你认为这些想法——其中一些是相当边缘的想法——在20世纪30年代期间，有多少渗透到了德国大众之中？嗯，这争议很大，不是吗？我当然不觉得我有资格对此下定论。但我的感觉是，如果不是大量的人在某种程度上接受了——哪怕只是直觉上——所宣传内容的本质有效性，这场战争就不会以那种方式进行。
I mean, I suppose a comparison might be with how deeply did people in the Soviet Union believe in Marxist ideology. I mean, if you're in a totalitarian state and this kind of stuff is being pumped at you all the time, then the default mode is basically just to accept it. And some people may well become true believers. And I think actually a kind of unsettling large number of people do. Because once you buy into the idea that morality is to be judged by the good of the race rather than by individuals or by universal standards. That's the big gear shift. And then everything follows from that. And if you're living in a society that is preaching that idea, the primacy of race, that everything is to be understood in terms of race, there is no other way of interpreting history or public morality or whatever, then I guess it would be very hard to kind of resist the implications of that.
我的意思是，我想一个比较可能是，苏联人民对马克思主义意识形态的信仰有多深。我的意思是，如果你身处一个极权国家，这种东西一直被灌输给你，那么默认模式基本上就是接受它。有些人很可能成为真正的信徒。而且我认为实际上有相当多令人不安的人确实如此。因为一旦你接受了道德应该由种族的利益来判断，而不是由个人或普世标准来判断的观点。这就是巨大的转变。然后一切都随之而来。如果你生活在一个宣扬这种思想的社会中，即种族的至高无上，一切都要从种族的角度来理解，没有其他方式来解释历史或公共道德等等，那么我想很难抵制这些含义。
Yeah. If there is no other way of thinking that is licit or permissible. And as you said, it's a shocking idea, but it is also one that has roots, as it were. Because even if you're not a sort of card-carrying racist, the language of race is kind of everywhere, isn't it, in the late 19th, early 20th century. Growing up in the 1920s and 1930s, even if you're not part of a Nazi milieu, the idea of racial struggle and the idea of there being races. Yeah. I mean, people in the democracies believe that.
是的。如果没有其他合法或允许的思维方式。正如你所说，这是一个令人震惊的想法，但它也有根源。因为即使你不是那种挂名的种族主义者，种族语言在19世纪末、20世纪初也随处可见，不是吗？在20世纪20年代和30年代成长起来，即使你不是纳粹圈子的一部分，种族斗争的想法和存在种族的想法。是的。我的意思是，民主国家的人们也相信这一点。
People in the United States or in Britain or France or wherever. Yeah. Well, so Thomas Mann, the great novelist who gone into exile by this point, I mean, he says that Hitler is the kind of the monstrous younger brother of the educated elites in Germany, and that effectively his genius is for articulating their kind of darkest desires and impulses. And I think there's probably a kind of element of truth to that. But of course, it does require an enormous moral revolution, because basically what the Nazis are saying is that the German people cannot afford to show compassion as it has been taught by the Christianity that has been the dominant ideology in Germany for centuries and centuries and centuries. The idea that individual rights or indeed universal values should govern how Germans think,
美国、英国、法国或其他任何地方的人。是的。嗯，托马斯·曼，那位当时已经流亡的伟大作家，他说希特勒是德国受过教育的精英们的某种怪异的弟弟，他的天才实际上在于表达了他们内心最黑暗的欲望和冲动。我认为这可能有一点道理。但当然，这确实需要一场巨大的道德革命，因为基本上纳粹所说的是，德国人民负担不起表现出同情心，正如几个世纪以来在德国占主导地位的基督教所教导的那样。个人权利或普世价值应该支配德国人思考的想法，
this is an expression of Jewish malevolence, that it has to be countered, that therefore there can be no place for compassion that is grounded in concern for the individual. Instead, the compassion must be framed in explicitly racial terms. So the good Nazi has to think, kind of, if you like, in terms of what is good for public racial health. And to be sure, you might come across a good Jew or a good gypsy, but so what? So there's an SS publication that gives a kind of very, very familiar scientific tinge to this question of, you know, what do you do with Jews you might be friends with or who've done you good turns or whatever. When you lie down in a hotel bed infested with bedbugs, you don't ask one specific bedbug, tell me, are you a good or a bad bedbug?
这是犹太人恶意的表现，必须予以反击，因此不能有基于对个人关怀的同情心。相反，同情心必须以明确的种族术语来界定。所以好的纳粹必须思考，如果你愿意的话，从对公共种族健康有益的角度来思考。当然，你可能会遇到一个好犹太人或一个好吉普赛人，但那又怎样？所以有一份党卫军出版物给这个问题带来了一种非常非常熟悉的科学色彩，你知道，你该如何处理你可能与之交朋友或对你有过恩惠的犹太人等等。当你躺在满是臭虫的酒店床上时，你不会问某一只特定的臭虫，告诉我，你是好臭虫还是坏臭虫？
You crush it. And Tom, this thing about suppressing individual morality and it being replaced by the collective morality, the idea of crisis, the idea of national struggle and all that, don't you think that it wouldn't have reached this sense of sort of almost hysterical urgency had it not been for the Great War? Because, of course, Germany has been through this enormous national trauma. Yeah. It's been humiliated. There has been a conflict in which individual rights have had to
你会把它捏死。汤姆，关于压制个人道德并将其替换为集体道德，关于危机感、民族斗争等等，你不觉得如果不是因为“大战”，它就不会达到这种近乎歇斯底里的紧迫感吗？因为，当然，德国经历了一场巨大的民族创伤。是的。它受到了羞辱。发生了一场冲突，其中个人权利不得不
be subordinated, not just in Germany, of course, but in the other competent nations as well, to the demands of the collective. And so that's laid a lot of the groundwork, hasn't it? And also, of course, it's meant that a lot of people are desensitized to violence. They've been brutalized on the Western Front or the Eastern Front. Do you think that's part of it too? Completely, because I think that the animating spirit of Nazism isn't necessarily, as I said before, a kind of strutting, arrogant self-confidence, although that I think comes in due course with the victories in the Second World War, but a kind of dread, a terror that Germany is going to disappear unless very,
被从属于集体的需求，当然不仅是在德国，在其他参战国也是如此。所以这奠定了许多基础，不是吗？而且，当然，这意味着很多人对暴力变得麻木了。他们在西线或东线变得残暴。你认为这也是其中的一部分吗？完全是，因为我认为纳粹主义的推动精神并不一定像我之前所说的那样，是一种昂首阔步、傲慢的自信，尽管我认为随着第二次世界大战的胜利，这种自信随之而来，而是一种恐惧，一种恐怖，即除非采取非常
very radical steps are taken. And the implications of this for people who are cast by the Nazis as racial enemies, so the Jews most obviously, but also the Roma, and of course the Slavs, the Poles, the Russians, whatever in due course, is completely terrifying. But it's terrifying also for racially pure Germans, as they would be defined by the Nazis, who can be cast as the equivalent of cancerous cells in the body politic of Germany, because they also have to be dealt with from the Nazi point of view. So an obvious example of that would be gay men who are targeted. Now, condemnation of homosexuality, which is a German word coined in the late 19th century, I mean, this is a Nazi inheritance. But actually, the Nazis are not opposed to male homosexuality really for moral reasons,
非常激进的措施，否则德国将会消失。对于那些被纳粹定性为种族敌人的人来说，这意味着什么——最明显的是犹太人，还有罗姆人，当然还有斯拉夫人、波兰人、俄罗斯人等等——是完全恐怖的。但对于纳粹定义的种族纯正的德国人来说，这也是恐怖的，因为他们可能被视为德国政治体中的癌细胞，因为从纳粹的角度来看，他们也必须被处理掉。一个明显的例子就是被针对的男同性恋者。现在，对同性恋的谴责，这是一个19世纪末创造的德语词汇，我的意思是，这是纳粹的遗产。但实际上，纳粹反对男同性恋并不是真的出于道德原因，
but for racial reasons. Because if you are a gay man and you are not breeding children, you are failing in your duty to the inheritance of the race. So this is why the Nazis had no real problem with lesbians, for instance. They regard lesbianism in the Reich as a consequence of the lack of men following on from the Great War. So they describe it as sexual distress caused by lack of men. And so once the Reich starts breeding enough men to keep women happy, lesbianism will end. This is the kind of thesis. And the Nazis also don't have a problem with foreign homosexuals because that's tremendous because it means that they won't be breeding. So that's absolutely brilliant. And predictably, they cast homosexuality
而是出于种族原因。因为如果你是一个男同性恋者，你没有繁衍后代，你就没有尽到种族传承的责任。这就是为什么纳粹对女同性恋者没有真正的问题，例如。他们认为帝国中的女同性恋是大战后男性缺乏的结果。所以他们将其描述为因缺乏男性而导致的性困扰。因此，一旦帝国开始繁衍足够的男性来让女性快乐，女同性恋就会结束。这就是这种论点。而且纳粹对外国同性恋者也没有问题，因为这太棒了，因为这意味着他们不会繁衍。所以这绝对是天才。不出所料，他们将同性恋
as being a Jewish disease that has been brought to the primordial swamps of Germany by Christian monks, and that it's monasticism that breeds the habit of homosexuality. Himmler, who's obsessed by this issue, says, well, we can see this from the evidence of ancient Germany. It's not clear quite how he knows all about this. He's probably drawing it from Tacitus. But he says, occasionally occasionally when incidences of homosexuality were discovered in the ancient german woods they would drown the offenders in bogs and he says again you know this was not a punishment but simply a matter of eliminating an abnormal life so it's kind of medicalizing morality okay so just on himmler can i just ask you a quick question about himmler i mean he'd
视为一种犹太疾病，是由基督教僧侣带到德国原始沼泽地的，而且是修道院制度滋生了同性恋的习惯。希姆莱，他对这个问题非常痴迷，说，嗯，我们可以从古代德国的证据中看到这一点。不清楚他到底是怎么知道这一切的。他可能是在引用塔西佗。但他确实说，偶尔偶尔在古代德国森林中发现同性恋事件时，他们会把罪犯淹死在沼泽里，他说，你知道，这并不是一种惩罚，而仅仅是消除一种异常生命的问题，所以这是一种将道德医学化的过程。好的，关于希姆莱，我能问你一个关于希姆莱的快速问题吗？我的意思是，他
be a brilliant subject for a podcast in itself, although a very sinister one. Himmler hates Christianity, doesn't he? He does. Does he hate Christianity because he thinks it's Jewish, or does he hate Christianity as it were, per se, Christianity in itself? Well, he hates Christianity because it's Jewish, but he recognises it as being Jewish because he sees it as fostering everything that he detests. So, I mean, he blames Christianity for homosexuality, for instance, which would come as news probably to quite a lot of people, but he blames it for fostering the ideals of softness and weakness and compassion that he
本身就是一个很棒的播客主题，尽管是一个非常阴险的主题。希姆莱讨厌基督教，不是吗？他确实讨厌。他讨厌基督教是因为他认为它是犹太人的，还是他讨厌基督教本身，即基督教本身？嗯，他讨厌基督教是因为它是犹太人的，但他之所以认为它是犹太人的，是因为他认为它助长了他所厌恶的一切。所以，我的意思是，他把同性恋归咎于基督教，例如，这可能对很多人来说是新闻，但他指责它助长了软弱、虚弱和同情心的理想，他
regards for the reasons that we've spelt out as being contemptible. So the same is, I think, even more evident in the Nazi attitude to people who are physically or mentally handicapped. And here again, the need to purge the Germans of the infection of Christianity is very, very palpable because of course you have the fifth commandment, thou shalt not kill. And Hitler explicitly detested the 10 commandments. He saw them as everything that the Nazi state existed to oppose. He declared that the Nazis were leading a great battle to save humanity from the curse of Mount Sinai, the mount on which Moses had received the Ten Commandments from God. And he sees the obedience of the Germans to the Ten Commandments,
认为，出于我们已经阐述的原因，这些是令人鄙视的。所以，我认为在纳粹对待身体或精神残疾者的态度上，这一点甚至更加明显。在这里，再次，净化德国免受基督教感染的必要性是非常非常明显的，因为当然你有第五诫，不可杀人。希特勒明确厌恶十诫。他认为它们是纳粹国家存在所要反对的一切。他宣称纳粹正在领导一场伟大的战斗，以拯救人类免受西奈山的诅咒，即摩西从上帝那里接受十诫的山。他认为德国人对十诫的服从，
that it's this that has led Germany to become diseased and the German people to be in, you know, kind of wasting away. And again, this is this attitude that a nation is faced with declining numbers, that the birth rate is falling, all this kind of thing, and that the racial stock is becoming corrupt is a common anxiety. But it's only in Nazi Germany that it gets weaponized to this, I mean, objectively mad degree. But there are eugenics, there are eugenicists everywhere. I mean, United States, in Britain, in France. I mean, eugenics is a big deal in the early 20th century, isn't it? It is. I mean, in pretty much every country,
正是这一点导致德国变得病态，德国人民正在，你知道，某种程度上正在消亡。同样，这种态度——一个国家面临人口下降，出生率下降，所有这些事情，以及种族储备正在变得腐败——是一种普遍的焦虑。但只有在纳粹德国，它才被武器化到这种，我的意思是，客观上疯狂的程度。但到处都有优生学，到处都有优生学家。我的意思是，美国、英国、法国。我的意思是，优生学在20世纪初是一件大事，不是吗？确实是。我的意思是，在几乎每个国家，
but it's in Nazi Germany that they really push it and that they kind of put their shoulder to the wheel of what the implications of eugenics properly are. So this is seen as an absolute priority for the Nazis when they come to power. So July 1933, a law is passed for the prevention of hereditarily diseased offspring. And this means compulsory sterilization for a broad array of medical categories. So people who suffer from schizophrenia, from cerebral palsy, hereditary epilepsy, hereditary deafness, blindness, manic depressive psychosis, severe alcoholism, or a very sinister phrase, congenital feeblemindedness. Feeblemindedness. Which of course, I mean, it's a catch-all yeah exactly so vague anyone could fall
但在纳粹德国，他们真正推动了它，他们某种程度上全力以赴地去实现优生学的真正含义。所以这被纳粹视为掌权后的绝对优先事项。因此，1933年7月，通过了一项预防遗传病后代的法律。这意味着对广泛的医疗类别进行强制绝育。所以那些患有精神分裂症、脑瘫、遗传性癫痫、遗传性耳聋、失明、躁郁症、严重酗酒的人，或者一个非常阴险的词，先天性弱智。弱智。这当然，我的意思是，这是一个包罗万象的词，是的，完全正确，如此模糊，任何人都可以落入
within that category but again the nazis are casting this as rigorously scientific so they're very proud of this they set up health courts where you have you have a judge and you have two doctors and the preamble to the law which sets this up explains that any resemblance to a criminal trial should be avoided because they're not blaming the diseased peoples, as they would describe them, in moral terms. You know, it's not their fault that they have it. But, you know, in a way, it's a sacrifice that the person who's being sterilized is taking on for the good of the race. And it's cast therefore as being both biological and as very moral. And again, history is invoked because you have the example of Sparta here, which is endlessly, endlessly being cited. The way in which the ancients
那个类别，但纳粹再次将其描述为严格的科学。所以他们对此非常自豪，他们建立了卫生法院，你有法官和两名医生，制定这项法律的前言解释说，应该避免任何与刑事审判的相似之处，因为他们不是在道德层面上指责那些患病的人，正如他们所描述的那样。你知道，他们患病不是他们的错。但是，你知道，在某种程度上，这是被绝育的人为了种族的利益而做出的牺牲。因此，它被描述为既是生物学的，也是非常道德的。而且，历史再次被引用，因为这里有斯巴达的例子，它被无休止地、无休止地引用。古人
kind of got rid of babies or infants or whatever, who didn't measure up to the standards that were required by the city or whatever. And because of this, because they're successfully able to frame these laws as being simultaneously scientifically justified and moral, they are able over the course of the thirties to kind of ratchet up the provision. So say 1935, so that's two years after the initial law is brought in. The period of appeal that the person who is condemned to sterilization has is reduced to 15 days. And 100,000, 200,000 in all over the period of the Nazi power are forcibly sterilized. But of course, Hitler, as war nears, as the prospect of a European conflict approaches, is worried that they're still not doing enough. The logical implication, again drawing on Sparta, is that you don't just content yourself with eugenic policy, but you go for a program of euthanasia and involuntary euthanasia.
某种程度上摆脱了婴儿或幼儿等等，那些不符合城市或其他地方要求的标准的人。正因为如此，因为他们能够成功地将这些法律框架为既是科学合理的又是道德的，他们能够在三十年代的过程中某种程度上提高供应。所以说1935年，也就是最初法律出台两年后。被判处绝育的人的上诉期缩短为15天。在纳粹统治期间，总共有10万、20万人被强制绝育。但当然，希特勒，随着战争临近，随着欧洲冲突的前景临近，担心他们做得还不够。逻辑上的含义，再次借鉴斯巴达，是你不仅满足于优生政策，而且还要进行安乐死和非自愿安乐死的计划。
In October 1939, Hitler makes the decision that people who he casts as genetically diseased should be eliminated. And he backdates this order to the 1st of September, which is the day the Reich goes to war. And I mean, you asked to what extent has this Nazi ideology kind of percolated through the whole of Germany? I mean, this causes a lot of moral revulsion in Germany. And in fact, in 1941, it inspires a bishop, the Bishop of Münster, Clemens von Galen, to openly condemn it in a sermon. And this sermon is widely, if illegally, reproduced. And it's actually one of the inspirations for the White Rose. The resistance movement that we talked about in a previous episode. But what is really striking is how many physicians back it.
1939年10月，希特勒做出决定，将他定性为遗传病的人应该被消灭。他将这项命令追溯到9月1日，也就是帝国开战的那一天。我的意思是，你问纳粹意识形态在多大程度上渗透到了整个德国？我的意思是，这在德国引起了很大的道德反感。事实上，1941年，它激励了一位主教，明斯特主教克莱门斯·冯·加伦，在布道中公开谴责它。这篇布道被广泛地（尽管是非法地）复制。它实际上是“白玫瑰”的灵感来源之一。我们在上一集中谈到的抵抗运动。但真正令人震惊的是有多少医生支持它。
So, I mean, the idea that Nazism appeals only to the, you know, goons of the SA or whatever. I mean, this is a comforting nonsense for anyone with pretensions to kind of intellectual aspiration. Physicians massively, massively back it yeah so chapiteau's book the law of blood opens with a trial of physicians who had participated in this program of involuntary euthanasia under the nazis in 1949 and they are exonerated they say look we're just doing what you know what the greeks and the romans did yeah we were doing nothing wrong we were following the science and they get let off in 1949 but this anticipates what we'll talk about next time, Tom, with anti-Semitism, with the Nazi dreams of the Jews, in which civil servants, people who work for local councils, doctors, lawyers were all ultimately implicated.
所以，我的意思是，纳粹主义只吸引冲锋队的暴徒之类的想法。我的意思是，这对任何有某种知识抱负的人来说都是一种令人安慰的胡说八道。医生们大规模地、大规模地支持它，是的，所以查皮托的书《血之法则》以1949年纳粹统治下参与这项非自愿安乐死计划的医生的审判开始，他们被免罪了，他们说，看，我们只是在做你知道的，希腊人和罗马人所做的事情，是的，我们没有做错任何事，我们是在遵循科学，他们被放走了，在1949年，但这预示了我们下次要谈论的内容，汤姆，关于反犹主义，关于纳粹对犹太人的梦想，其中公务员、为地方议会工作的人、医生、律师最终都牵连其中。
Yeah, absolutely. And so on that note and setting up where we're going to go in the next two episodes, I just want to quote a physician in 1940 who is responding very specifically to misgivings that have been expressed by a Lutheran pastor. So objections to this program of forced euthanasia being expressed both by Catholics and by Protestants. And this physician, a guy called Jürgen Stahler, replies, Where God's will truly reigns, that is in in pure nature one finds no trace of pity for the weak and diseased you will not see a diseased rabbit survive more than a few days it will fall prey to its enemies and in this way will be relieved of its suffering this is why rabbits are a society which is always a hundred percent healthy i mean right that's clearly not true but
是的，绝对。所以以此为契机，并为我们接下来的两集做铺垫，我只想引用一位1940年的医生的话，他非常具体地回应了一位路德教牧师表达的疑虑。所以天主教徒和新教徒都对这个强制安乐死计划表示反对。而这位医生，一个叫尤尔根·斯塔勒的人，回答说，在上帝的旨意真正统治的地方，也就是在纯粹的自然界中，人们找不到对弱者和病者的怜悯，你不会看到一只生病的兔子能活过几天，它会成为敌人的猎物，并以这种方式减轻它的痛苦，这就是为什么兔子是一个永远百分之百健康的社会，我的意思是，对，这显然不是真的，但
by the by the fifth commandment thou shalt not kill is not a commandment from god but a jewish invention through which the jews the biggest murderers history has ever known always attempt to prevent their enemies from effectively defending themselves all the better to exterminate them after that and this is a doctor saying this this is a doctor saying this and i think again in answer to your question how widely have nazi ideas that are coming from the Nazi hierarchy percolated down? I mean, I think that that is a perfect illustration of all the themes that we've been talking about. Because what you have in that answer is an emphasis on the health of the race over the health of the individual, that true morality exists in protecting the racial stock rather than diseased individuals.
顺便说一句，第五诫“不可杀人”不是上帝的诫命，而是犹太人的发明，通过它，历史上最伟大的杀人犯犹太人，总是试图阻止他们的敌人有效地保卫自己，以便在那之后更好地消灭他们，这是一个医生说的，这是一个医生说的，我认为再次回答你的问题，纳粹高层传出的纳粹思想渗透到了什么程度？我的意思是，我认为这是一个完美的例证，说明了我们一直在谈论的所有主题。因为你在那个回答中拥有的是强调种族的健康高于个人的健康，真正的道德存在于保护种族储备而不是患病的个人。
The biological metaphors, you know, comparing humans to rabbits. The emphasis on struggle. Yeah. The contempt for the Ten Commandments, for biblical injunctions from the dictates of religious dogma. And of course, blaming the Jews. The Jews are the biggest murderers history has ever known. Everything is always the fault of the Jews.
生物学隐喻，你知道，把人类比作兔子。强调斗争。是的。对十诫的蔑视，对宗教教条指令的圣经禁令的蔑视。当然，还有指责犹太人。犹太人是历史上最伟大的杀人犯。一切总是犹太人的错。
And Dominic, in the next two episodes, the last two episodes of this series that we've been doing on the Nazis in power, we're going to look specifically at what this ideology meant for German Jews. Yes, a fascinating subject, but also a very chilling one and a particularly chilling note, Tom, on which to end. Thank you for that. That was incredibly interesting and also terrifying. So everybody, we will see you for the last two episodes of the series. Of course, if you remember the Reuters History Club, you can listen to them right away. But if not, we will see you next time for The Nazis Against the Jews. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
多米尼克，在接下来的两集里，也就是我们一直在做的关于纳粹掌权的这个系列的最后两集，我们将专门研究这种意识形态对德国犹太人意味着什么。是的，一个迷人的主题，但也是一个非常令人不寒而栗的主题，汤姆，这是一个特别令人不寒而栗的结束语。谢谢你。这非常有趣，也令人恐惧。所以大家，我们将在该系列的最后两集再见。当然，如果你记得路透社历史俱乐部，你可以马上收听它们。但如果没有，我们下次再见，届时将讨论《纳粹反对犹太人》。再见。再见。再见。揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场票的权限，请前往... 目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。